Escribe "d" por "4d"a la cuarta,
elevado a la un medio como una expresión radical,
el punto clave aquí es,
tomar en cuenta que por definición,
si elevó a algo a la un medio,
esto es igual,
a la raíz cuadrada principal de ese algo,
vamos a aplicar eso aquí,
donde tenemos  "4d" a la cuarta
elevado a la un medio
y lo voy a hacer con dos colores...
aquí tenemos entonces "d"
que multiplica a "4d"  a la cuarta
elevada a la un medio,
lo cual por definición,
es la raíz cuadrada principal
de "4d" a la cuarta,
ya te mostraré en otros vídeos el por qué es posible
aplicar esta propiedad de los exponentes.
Y esto lo podemos simplificar como...
ya sabemos que aquí estamos buscando
la raíz principal de esto de aquí,
déjame escribirlo de la siguiente manera.
Esto es igual a "d" por la raíz principal de 4,
por la raíz principal de "d" a la cuarta...
la raíz principal de "d2 a la cuarta...
la raíz principal de 4 es 2,
por supuesto,
tenemos el "d" por delante,
"d" por 2 por la raíz principal de "d" la cuarta,
la raíz principal de "d" a la cuarta es
"d" cuadrada... "d" cuadrada...
y no tengo que preocuparme
por el valor absoluto,
pues aunque "d" sea negativo,
al elevarla al cuadrado
siempre va a ser positiva,
si dentro del radical tuviéramos "d" cuadrada,
entonces si tendríamos que pensar
en incluir el valor absoluto aquí,
y esto a la vez podemos simplificarlo,
como tenemos "d" por 2 por "d" cuadrada
esto va a ser igual, tenemos "d" cuadrada y "d",
la misma base
podemos sumar los exponentes para obtener "d" a la tercera potencia, si es que esto es igual a
2 por "d" cúbica.
Ahora otra manera de hacer esto,
es un uso directo
de las propiedades de los exponentes,
así es que esto es igual a
"d" por lo que está dentro del paréntesis
y aquí hay que tomar en cuenta, que si tienes
el producto de algo y luego elevado a un exponente,
eso es lo mismo a elevar al exponente
cada uno de los términos individualmente
y luego realizar el producto
por lo que esta parte de aquí,
la puedo reescribir como
4 elevada a la potencia un medio
por "d" a la cuarta elevada a la potencia un medio,
ahora 4 elevado a la un medio es,
literalmente la raíz principal de 4,
que es 2
y "d" a la cuarta elevada a la un medio,
aquí vamos a aplicar
la siguiente propiedad de los exponentes,
si tenemos algo elevado al "b"
y esto a la vez elevado a la "c"
esto lo mismo a ese algo,
elevado al producto de los exponentes
"ab" por "c"
y esto te lo probaré alguna vez en otro vídeo.
Aplicando esa propiedad aquí,
tenemos "d" a la cuarta elevada de un medio
es "d" a la 4 por un medio,
4 por un medio es 2,
así es que estoy aquí es "d" al cuadrado
y que tenemos lo mismo,
"d" por 2 por "d" cuadrada,
lo cual es igual a "2d" cúbica.